hey guys it is the third of sep tember
my name is just and here's what mattered
in gaming today fallout 4 certainly
sounds like it's going to be one massive
game considering the most recent news
that it has more lines of dialogue and
then Skyrim and the fallout three
combined that's a lot of chatter but
those to reveal the massive bigger on
Twitter today where they said many years
of Fallout 4 voice recording complete
just sir but 111,000 align more than
fallout 3 and Skyrim combined wow that's
bound to be a hell of a lot of side
quests and options to display your
characters less-than-stellar
intelligence stat should you choose to
go that route it's not all that
surprising that fallout saw will feature
more dialogue pull out bubble ship on
blu-ray discs and digital downloads
which don't face the same space
restrictions that fallout 3 and Skyrim
did when they [ __ ] well outdoor also
features a voiced protagonist for the
first time in this series the
notoriously broken batman arkham knight
for pc has received a wonderful patch
which some users were able to try out
early unfortunately it's not quite ready
yet water brothers deployed a 626
megabyte patch for the pc version
yesterday before removing it claiming
that it went live too early it may not
be ready yet but according to those who
got their hands on it in beta form it's
really impressive some users reported
completely maxed graphics settings in
the game running at 60 frames per second
constantly and a screen grab of the
extensive new graphics options coming
with the patch Warner Brothers have
suggested that the rest of us will be
able to get our hands on the patch later
this month finally today Mortal Kombat X
will be getting additional playable
characters next year Warner Brothers has
confirmed that the fighting game will be
getting another deal CPAC and if you
want to play super sleuths detective you
might even be able to guess what's in it
series creator Ed Boon shed an image of
four silhouettes which appear to tease
the up
coming characters given the predator and
jason voorhees with inclusion it could
be almost anyone in addition to these
playable characters the upcoming DLC
will also include more skins and a new
environments but Warner Brothers did not
release any specific release date for
pricing info the first combat DLC pack
costs 30 bucks let me know down in that
comment section which character you'd
like to see come to mortal kombat x you
can add the game spot where we've got
news on fallout monopoly and definitely
going offline let me know down in that
comment box what mattered to you today
and be sure to pop by same time tomorrow
for my top 5 stories of the whole gaming
week I will see you then